27 seconds of logo I see that the
poorest Weasley's were able to rebuild
their house from the last movie either
through magic or Wizarding insurance I
guess we didn't need to worry about that
smash and burn job from half-blood
prince that didn't matter
aren't my knees parents including
Catelyn Stark going to wonder why they
sell out so many empty picture frames or
the why the room upstairs has teenage
girls clothes and accessories throughout
and the other muggles who know for a
fact they have a daughter
here's another movie character walking
down the center of the damn road instead
of either side it makes for a more
symmetrical shot but also a more
mathematically possible death part one
as inspiring as I find your bloodlust
Bellatrix I must be the one to kill
Harry Potter makes sense to me my wand
and Potter's share the same call we can
wound but not fatally harm one another
what a bunch of bull you make it sound
like the wand is actually part of the
owners physical being and that twin
wands no not to kill each other which
can't be true besides we've seen Wizards
using magic without wands his entire
series and the rules have never been
explained once if I am to kill him I
must do it with another's wom movie
makes this sound like a huge problem
when it should basically be sure thing
boss I'll just buy another one later you
see the scene pays off a lot more if the
rules wands were ever covered yeah we
get this is a big deal and Voldemort
taking Malfoy Swan means something but
that's the art of storytelling that was
lost with the scene when the series
decided against saying anything about it
Harry opens the door without checking
who's there the very moment here he
decides to say goodbye to the house and
leave is the moment everyone who wants
to help him shows up so you have to use
those means of transport the trace can
detect brooms test holes in the like the
Ministry can't detect when an underage
wizardry uses flying brooms does that
mean some normal a smuggle motherfucker
can get on a flying broom and make it
work also why didn't they just use a
port key or anything they used in the
other chapters that Harry was able to
use without the Ministry knowing or
getting pissed about it you'll ride with
Hagrid I brought you here 16 years ago
when you were no bigger than a boat
Runkle doesn't hang it's connection to
Harry make him the most likely target in
case someone is watching kept the Ron
Weasley Harry go with Hagrid
are we still going with the muggles
never cease angle when it comes to these
terribly obvious loud magic motorcycles
why did all the fake Harry Potter's
write out the same goddamn direction as
the real Harry Potter I didn't they
scatter from the launch site movie
answers the burning question what if
Michael Bay directed a Harry Potter
movie
Hedwig summons his inner eagle and shows
up to save Harry only problem is like
don't remember Hedwig showing up for
anything other than sending messages
before the scene crossing the wand
streams that we won't see this a dozen
more times or anything wait a minute
that was literally Baltimore and he can
actually get caught in the powerlines
god man what the hell is happening No
also I guess the most powerful wizard
ever is no match for a rocket booster
why did they choose the Weasley place to
hide Harry one of the most obvious
places for him to stay whoa time fucking
out why is this woman watching her own
pots and pans we've seen tons of
explicit shots throughout these movies
of magical self scrubbing dish and
cookware in the kitchen so this shot is
a bullshit magic got them here but can't
do much to help with the nearly deadly
crash landing what creature sat in the
corner the first time Harry Potter
visited my office in ha good Jesus man
that was like four movies ago and
Harry's not a great student are you
gonna kill him if he doesn't remember
with the glasses part of the potion
costume how come Ron still has Harry
glasses on but several other fake
Harry's don't funny how Lupin and
Kingsley were on their guard earlier
making sure everyone was who they said
they were but now every new arrival is
just assumed to be good yeah it's sad
but this family has spells to do the
dishes but not to heal the wounded
mundungus to one look of old moon to
separate it wait a minute disapp irate
means the same thing as a parade i feel
like dr. nick when he finds out
inflammable means flammable so it is to
put the chase on you still got the
wedding what a wedding the love of Bill
and Fluer needs to have a full-blown
ceremony and everything while all the
Voldemort goes down magic newspaper is
so stupid and annoying I don't even
wanna bother checking the articles for
accuracy it takes six people to pitch a
tent in the series and all that that
implies
Rufus proves that any asshole can come
wandering into the highly protected
Weasley farm without any resistance to
what do we owe the pleasure minister I
think we both know the answer to that
question mr. Potter
you mean Dumbledore left me something in
his will of course - Ronald
bilious Weasley I leave my deluminator
when things seem most
Dok it will show him the light okay so
now the deluminator is something i
probably call an illuminator what's with
the weird anti names and couldn't have
just given him a flashlight this
gathering exacerbates even more the idea
of putting on a wedding during this time
allegiances are iffy people can change
into other people nothing is certain did
they ask all these party guests a secret
question to prove who they were what was
your high school mascot the rains of
castamere isn't playing right now to
signal the impending and shocking
bloodbath hermione is definitely old
enough to be hot now right right what
has it that someone talked to her Jesus
one of the chances of Harry sitting down
next to a newspaper columnist who just
happens to be sitting close to a town
gossip who just happens to know a name
and location of a person here he needs
to see to advance the plot at this
wedding party that defies common sense
how in Harry have gotten this name any
other way what's the point of all the
magical protection if these smokey dicks
can just come in without the slightest
delay these people walking into the
coffee shop are here to kill Harry
Potter but miss their best chance to do
it and inexplicably wait until they're
at the counter to pull out their wands
tipping off Harry well before they
attack and giving them better defense
options also how the fuck did they know
Harry was in here movie rips off the
amazing spider-man or inspires it or
shares storyboards with the production
team by the way what the hell magic
spells are they using that don't require
any fake latin to work if we kill them
the low evil head apparently they
already know you're here so what the
fuck
open it he ate well that's the second
time that spell is needed to be used but
I can't help but think that this was
invented specifically for this movie and
a ripoff men in black maybe you still
have the trace on you
Combee choice breaks a 17 is whizzed
along how long does a story been going
harry wasn't 17 when mad I and everybody
came to his house and now he is but damn
it's been like what a week they couldn't
wait until Harry turned 17 so he could
do magic without the trace
Oh salable probably mad house idea
okay Snape decided to come snooping if
you say so it clearly had you guys
running out the door so a master wizard
like Snape would definitely appeal his
pants and rant oh my name reveille oh
we're alone how did that magic spell
know not to include Harry and Ron in the
search results
sweet bark - Harry Potter and the
Chamber of flashbacks the director's cut
now that forty minutes have passed we
can officially bring you bonus footage
they couldn't show you in theaters of
mere 17 minutes ago future romantic
pairing makes zero sense given what I
know about attraction so movie ignores
me and puts in this cutesy their hands
almost touch while they're sleeping seen
to have Harry Potter fan squeak or
whatever we call it orgasms these days
Harry goes into his dead uncle's room
which gives me pause and makes me feel
sad because Harry spent all night on the
couch when he could have just slept on
this bed what you found a bed - damn
there are beds all over the place it
makes you wonder why they decided to
spend time sleeping on the couches and
the floor Oh Regulus Arcturus black all
right B you know Rab surely you remember
that from the quick glimpse of Harry's
Hitchhiker's Guide to Horcruxes earlier
in the movie or that brief mention of
Rab and the half-blood Prince that came
out of here and a half before this one
you remember they were trying to figure
out who that was trying I got to tell
you something embarrassing I completely
forgot all so much like everything in
this series something once considered
hard to figure out is handed to them on
a hairy bladder so that they can advance
the hairy bladder and I will be dead
long before you read this I know I will
be long dead before you read watch we're
here this cliche oh good now someone who
could Vance the plot even further is
hiding in the closet right this very
moment did someone take it okay in the
night he took many things including the
locket he doesn't really have a name but
definitely a penis cute piano lessons
who will see the way she knock now but
this random newspaper on the floor does
I'm just gonna sit down and relax
because Harry's entire quest is gonna be
solved by plot BOTS movie puts in the
guy from the departed who you didn't
know was also in Braveheart and expects
me not to be distracted by that flush
ourselves here yeah I don't believe it
either this is supposedly some secret
way for ministry people to get to their
job but it's a public urinal any regular
asshole could walk in and figure out
things aren't quite right also
travelling by toilet also come on
knuckles in their rightful place how do
you know that's not just a fucked up
decoration you can see should like this
in just about any city but I never once
thought yep there are some dead people
it's still raining inside my office
that's two days now and there's
absolutely no spell on the Wizarding
World that stops that now dust a bit
rainy try if any Titan can't autumn
because not even the asshole upstairs
could figure out such an easy spell I'd
say if we don't locate Humbert within
the owl we go find Ron and come back
another day let me guess
yeah yeah she is I'm pretty sure this
Albert dude isn't supposed to be in
court just from the elevator scene
earlier when Dolores asked why he wasn't
getting out so now that he's drawing a
wand I'm wondering why there aren't a
ton of paranoid witches and wizards
instantly slinging disarming spells in
his direction because after all
Dementors can't get through elevator
cages even if they're pretty much smoke
why did you wait so long to do this no
one notices the most famous and wanted
wizard in the world in the middle of the
Ministry of Magic and are there really
no alarms going off right now knocked
out real husband shows up just in time
to see Weasley fake husband kiss his
wife also is there any reason why you
would show up for work in your
undergarments after getting knocked out
and left in a room somewhere probably
after your liver was extracted for the
black market you don't want a magic
spell some clothes on again what's the
spell is it a stupefy spell the kill
spell a Speak & Spell and this guy has
horrible aim despite the fact that I
feel like magic should be able to
correct any deficiencies here's the
terrence malick portion of the movie
only one of many reasons why this bolt
is so long as to require two parts very
quickly in my bag miss Hermione waiting
until here we got up to even think about
the medicine she's carrying around in
her bag was she just gonna worry over
Ron until here he could do something she
easily could have done come on his own
what do you think she's asking you to
get the medicine for what happened I
thought we went to going back to Google
place we won't be were there we would
ever you actually had hold of min I knew
once you seen where we worried we could
stay so her borders head how do you go
through the flu Network thing and change
your mind midway through the journey but
also take two friends with you and leave
the bad guy behind don't your friends
have to know where you're going for that
door this is some bolt right here magic
work so quickly and completely I wonder
why they even worried about it are there
any rules concerning the protective
enchantments these wizards are always
putting up around themselves can they be
broken or do they just delay a surprise
attack they didn't matter at the Weasley
house earlier where am I supposed to
find a tent again this bag with a spell
that makes it home everything is somehow
so useful you wonder why there are any
conflicts in the magic world in sungeun
this is exactly what her mighty in this
movie is saying to my heart
so how does the fire spill not burn the
dried leaves surrounding the amulet
Reducto after a series of spoken spells
Harry then throws three unspoken spells
at the amulet illustrating my number one
problem with this entire goddamn series
Dumbledore sends you off to fondle these
Horcruxes but doesn't tell you how to
destroy them does not bother you it does
me Harry's flashbacks part 3 the
extended prisoner's cut up Azkaban
that's a fight but it's my burden to
bear Samwise Gamgee movie veers wildly
into summer camp / Hunger Games
territory for most of the rest of the
film actually and I don't like it it's
smut my perfume what the fearing perfume
for Owen isn't strong enough to operate
I'll go on foot now that seems like some
pretty convenient plot device right
there here begins one of the most
infuriating parts of the entire series
the Ron gets jealous of Harry and
Hermione rigmarole the entire part one
will waste loads of time on this and
camping if this movie had been a
standalone film that didn't depend on
every other part before it it would have
made for quit at the box office
watch it guys there's a mimic hiding
somewhere in one of these trailers in
the Chamber of Secrets you stopped the
basilisk with the Sword of Gryffindor
its blade is impregnated with basilisk
venom well damn that's convenient sanity
why Dumbledore left it to you in his
will I can maybe see why he didn't spell
it the reason for the sword in his will
but couldn't you have at least left a
riddle you are brilliant Himani
surely except for the perfume thing I
still can't fake that about you - carry
on then let me spoil the fun too late
you think on all these things who you
think I don't know how this family
skipped salvio hexia
/ feliz finito I feel badly about what
happened between Ron on them it's gonna
take a whole movie before I get over we
can waste time because there's a part to
dance snitch tasting hidden Warner's ex
machina he doesn't pause the book
somebody drew it Lunas dad was wearing
that that bill and fleurs wedding that
bull wedding was beyond helpful to the
quest they never bothered ask anyone
would it men so a completely random
run-in with the dude from Notting Hill
completely saves their ass here you know
who almost died dead haven't you guys
long been calling in Baltimore no longer
scared of the name isn't that exactly
the type of place he'd be lighting - hi
- aw crud why didn't Voldemort bury a
Horcrux under an ask Italian restaurant
or somewhere not obvious why was he so
sentimental as to where parts of his
soul were hidden Hermione wipes off the
one grave that just so happens to have
the symbol important for the story so
the plan was to turn the snake into
Bagshot and then attack
Carrie once he got him into the house
first off the snake is one of the
Horcruxes so that puts one of them in
immediate danger second off why don't
you just have someone else be Bagshot
who could just do vada Kedavra Harry
into oblivion sneak besides I'll just go
with a jump-scare attack surely it will
catch them completely off-guard because
they started playing Monopoly after I
fell in the hole before poor camping I
tried to mend it but ones are different
it's done
leave me yours and there was no drama
about Harry taking her my tease want
I'll tell the lock is as well is there
any reason why they still need to take
turns wearing the locket couldn't they
just leave it in the tent or something
the locket has apparently like the ring
and Lord of the Rings but they aren't
transporting it to Mount Doom they're
just camping it's no need for the burden
at least not right now apparently and
there's no spell for warmth a second
dear Jesus returns to ex machina the
head of this series even more need a
break in the case Harry here's the
glowing beer of Requirement just think
if Hermione's parents had never taken
her out here years ago they would have
never camped you and Harry would never
have gotten a visit from the hallowed
ear of truth to lead him to the Sword of
Gryffindor which is randomly here like a
treasure in an RPG these stories need to
go to rehab for how many times they rely
on four leaf clover appearances and
rabbit's foot magic to bail the main
characters out all the more smokey
drive-in theater plays a PG
representation of rounds were sphere
also Ron's worst fear is more likely to
make him angry rather than scared so you
should have kept it up with the spiders
and now you're dead Horcrux you are so
very dead and how is it you just happen
to have the Sword of Gryffindor it's a
long story
well no it's not actually all that long
it's just unbelievable as all Christmas
morning I was sleeping in this little
pub keep it away from some Snatchers and
I heard it uh-huh
those it's have powerful sound don't
think so here's Ron explaining that the
thing Dumbledore gave him not only does
funny things with lights
it also takes you wherever you need to
go if you hear a voice let a light
pierce your heart and like Huey Lewis
believed in the power of love we'll
never hear about this thing again
because it's just here to keep the plot
moving but man what a useful thing this
could be if it could take them to the
Horcruxes oh well I'm already forgot
about it ding just hope the one is he
would show yourself he did well no Harry
was underwater and drowning so he did
not show himself
it's amazing you even came by the pond
in the dark but what the hell do we
expect at this point I'm going to have
Ron Weasley's baby's face I've always
liked his flames from my teammates me
too oh you meant the literal got it
think he knew somehow I'd need it to
fajn way back she'd leave me if
Dumbledore had that kind of foresight he
wouldn't be dead he needed one thing
according to this movie's foreseen
casual wand exchanges can lead to STDs
but Harry can pick whatever wand he
wants because doh religion allows it
for ten inches nothing special science
queen took off eccentric why is this
dialogue about wands and Snatchers
making me anxious
it keeps cropping up beetle apart in the
graveyard in Godric's hollow it was
there take Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows Part wand rise to break the
pronoun game record synchronize
tea-drinking it's a symbol you mean this
yes Benjamin gates one already have this
magical Knights Templar both solved well
well it's the sign of the Deathly
Hallows of course roll credits you're
all familiar with the tale of the three
brothers I have it in here of course you
do
though wants three brothers who were
traveling along a lonely winding road at
Twilight midnight mum oh I said midnight
but it's all's fine better actually
Ron betrays the Harry Potter series by
saying Twilight is better I bet he's
even on Team Jacob that bastard also Ron
is only in this movie to boost the run
time through buffoonery that is
excessive even by Ron standards now the
movies taking a page from Prince of
Egypt because really what choice did
they have after decided to devote
several minutes of screen time to a
character reading us a children's story
only when he attained great age did the
youngest brother shed the cloak of
invisibility and give it to his son wait
did the youngest brother fuck with the
cloak of invisibility on how did he get
a wife when he was invisible the
youngest brother had some mad game they
were angry you see what I've been
writing sorry took the heroes touched a
thing and are instantly whisked to a
place a place that just happens to put
them in the middle of a bunch of
Snatchers I'm just gonna take note of
how they completely abandoned their bags
and backpacks here because I'm assuming
at some later point in time they're
going to magically reproduce something
that was in one of those bags let's spin
Salinas in here and I'll take it off
later if I'm wrong why are they running
why not run together and operate again
why not use that spell you used in the
first goddamn movie that turned Neville
frozen God these movies drive me fucking
crazy a foot chase in a super-powered
magical wizard movie should just not
happen the shaky-cam is strong with this
one once again a magical person does not
need to speak the spell out loud in
order for it to work and this one is
extremely specific Harry Potter's
flashbacks part for the Goblet of
remembering the Elder Wand
lies with him course of course him you
know sound the elephant you mean just
now you've been dreaming this for months
what has Baltimore been doing this whole
time and once with the continued use of
you know who you pansy ass mother fucker
all bad guys are rapist yes
what is wrong with his face he came to
us like that something he puts up in the
forest I reckon ran into a stinging
jeans or a crackerjack er am i right
give me I wond we'll see what her last
spell was wands are fine iPhones now it
was in a back when we searched ah so you
dumb assholes Trek back the 500 yards
you chased them to retrieve the
backpacks call me skeptical well the
thing they keep a lantern handy down in
the Malfoy dungeons what are you doing
here
don't bees come to rescue Harry Potter
of course dopey will always be there for
Harry Potter except when he fights a
snake or when the snatcher is decide to
take him to the Malfoy house in the
first place but shirt dobby's there to
save Harry Potter I know Wormtail is
stupid but not thankfully Bellatrix is
taking her sweet ass time interrogating
Hermione so that there will still be a
home writing for these dudes to say
Dobby prefers the unhook the chandelier
and cause a disturbance method rather
than using own elf magic to save the
heroes of course the old falling
chandelier gag causes Bellatrix to shove
Hermione away from herself and toward
Harry and Ron man that gag is
consistently useful don't be only meant
to maim or seriously injure larious but
can't health magic do the same thing
Dobby is a free elf because of that
accidental sock loophole I will never
forget that bull why did they need
dobby's help operating at this point
they have wands they were doing it on
their own earlier man also operating
will now take forever so that Bellatrix
has time to throw a knife across the
room before it's over
Bellatrix his knife goes into a
disappearing vortex of whirlwind wolf
and still somehow ends up stabbing Dobby
with it that should be nice tell me
about the rabbits George movie expects
me to feel horrible for dotty and movie
is wrong because the movie is
responsible for putting him in this
situation
Dobby funeral now he's SuperDuper
powerful now that Voldemort is upgraded
he's no longer a piece of
run-of-the-mill wizard
damn 2 hours 26 minutes of setup awesome
goodbye money also half a movie is half
a movie and oh yeah 12 minutes of
credits between two pillows those aren't
pillows
gentlemen I want this terror is found
and I want him to understand what terror
really means England prevails blue is
Atlantis off the bats who keeps the
Martians under wraps
the Lord tells me he can get me out of
this mess but he's pretty sure you're ah
you you're at risk
maybe no movies characters were more
needing of a nature box membership than
Harry Ron and Hermione in Deathly
Hallows Part 1 they spent half the movie
on the run in the woods a perfect
scenario for healthy energy providing
snacks and in the Harry Potter universe
I'm thinking that version of nature box
can deliver that stuff buying like owl
directly to wherever you happen to be in
the world right I mean awesome
here in the real world nature box does
not deliver by owl
say it ain't so Jill st. so what they do
the next best thing
free shipping direct to your door if you
want to get in on the deliciousness and
be more prepared than Harry freakin
Potter was head on over to
naturebox.com/tyler send you a free
sampler for your first month containing
five of their most popular snacks
so the next time you're running from
evil wizards and hiding out and
ridiculously huge on the inside tents
make sure your stomach is taken care of
with some tasty snacks trail mix seems
like a perfect choice for the occasion
wouldn't you say
brilliant a lazy naturebox comments free
sampler box of awesome snacks I can't
think of any reason why you're still
watching this move out